EMILY FORTUNA: Hello.
I'm Emily Fortuna for
The Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Coral is a platform for
building intelligent devices
with local AI.
It offers a complete
local AI toolkit
that makes it easy to grow
your ideas from prototype
to production.
This includes hardware
components, software tools,
and content that helps
you create, train,
and run neural networks
locally on your device.
To learn more, head
on over to the post
linked in the description below.
TensorFlow 2.0 alpha is here.
This new version
of TensorFlow is
about providing
simple and easy to use
higher level APIs, focused
on Keras and eager execution.
The big announcement came
at the TensorFlow Dev
Summit in Sunnyvale,
California this last week.
Other highlights included
new online courses
from Deep Learning AI
and Udacity, as well as
a Powered By TF challenge.
Click the links below
for our top five recap
video, the recap blog post, or
the full playlist of sessions.
Gpipe is a distributor
machine learning
library that uses synchronous
stochastic gradient descent
and pipeline
parallelism for training
applicable to any deep
neural network that consists
of multiple sequential layers.
It allows you to easily
deploy more accelerators
to train larger
models and to scale
the performance without tuning
those annoying hyperparameters.
Graphs and a link to the
GitHub repo are on the post.
Android Jetpack
WorkManager 1.0 Stable
is available with some
great new features.
The latest version
of WorkManager
lets you set constraints, such
as network status or charge
state when the
task runs, supports
asynchronous one-off
and periodic tasks,
allows chain tasks with input
and output, and much more.
For the intro video and sample
code, take a look at the post.
You can simplify enterprise
threat detection and protection
with new Google Cloud
security services,
such as the Web Risk API,
which is now in beta.
With a simple API call,
client applications
can check URLs against Google's
list of unsafe web resources,
including social
engineering sites,
like phishing and
deceptive sites, and sites
that host malware or
unwanted software.
To learn more about
this and other tools,
click through to post.
Chrome 74 is available!
This includes the ability to
highlight all nodes affected
by a CSS property, which
is super cool, a WebSocket
binary message viewer,
performance panel
updates, and much more.
This whole list
with screenshots is
on the post linked in
the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Emily Fortuna for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching.
Dev Show will be
on break next week,
but we will see you in
two weeks for episode 150!
(ACCENT) How about I
do this whole thing
in this strange accent.
It's reminiscent of 1930s.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
EMILY FORTUNA:
(ACCENT) I don't know.
OK, all right.